Est-ce que vous connaissez
la « légende des escaliers » ?
Bon,
vous savez que les correcteurs des concours
doivent lire des centaines de dissertations
;
qu’ils n’ont pas beaucoup de temps,
et puis que ce n’est pas une tâche passionnante.
Eh bien,
d’après la légende,
un jour,
un correcteur a trouvé une solution :
il a monté vingt marches,
et il a jeté en l’air son paquet de copies.
Après,
il avait juste à les ramasser une par une,
et à noter le numéro de la marche.
Ah là,
l’élève va être déçu !
Comment s’y prendre pour décrocher
vingt sur vingt
en dissertation de culture générale
aux concours des grandes écoles de commerce
à HEC,
par exemple,
ou à l’ESSEC ?
Alors,
c’est tout à fait possible,
parce que chaque année,
des dizaines d’élèves décrochent
la note maximale
en dissertation de culture générale.
En 2017,
par exemple,
45 candidats,
soit 0,6 pour cent de tous les candidats
— ce qui fait un peu plus d’un sur 200
—
donc en 2017,
un candidat sur 200
a eu vingt
à l’épreuve de dissertation de culture
générale
de HEC.
Seulement...
ce n’est pas toujours mérité !
Vous allez voir :
la copie que je vais commenter dans cette
vidéo
est loin d’être parfaite !
L’élève a eu un coup de chance.
Et en effet,
aux concours,
il y a des surprises,
et dans les deux sens.
Si vous voulez réussir
la dissertation de culture générale,
MAIS que vous ne voulez pas
vous en remettre à la chance,
alors vous avez besoin d’une méthodologie
TRÈS EFFICACE.
Eh bien j’ai ce qu’il vous faut :
inscrivez-vous
à mon cours gratuit de méthodologie.
Le lien doit s’afficher maintenant en haut
à droite de la vidéo,
et vous pouvez aussi le trouver
dans la description.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc vous pouvez regarder cette vidéo en
entier,
et puis vous découvrirez ma méthodologie
après,
ou un autre jour.
Alors maintenant,
je vous donne les informations essentielles
avant de commencer à commenter la dissertation.
Le sujet c’est
« Faut-il toujours préférer la vérité
? ».
Il est tombé en 2015
à l’épreuve de l’ESSEC/EDHEC,
qui sont deux
des meilleures écoles de commerce françaises.
Le thème de l’année,
comme vous l’avez peut-être deviné,
c’était « la vérité ».
Et par rapport à ce thème,
le sujet était facile.
Déjà,
c’était une question fermée,
et puis beaucoup d’élèves avaient certainement
déjà traité
des sujets comparables dans leur prépa HEC
au cours de l’année.
À mes yeux,
c’est même un sujet niveau Bac.
En comparaison,
le sujet qui était tombé à HEC la même
année,
— « Crépuscule de la vérité » —
était BIEN plus difficile.
Concernant la copie,
vous la verrez à l’écran
pendant mon commentaire :
vous verrez le bon passage ;
je soulignerai les phrases,
les mots que je mentionne ;
donc vous n’avez pas besoin de la copie
pendant que vous regardez la vidéo.
Mais si vous voulez la télécharger,
je vous ai mis le lien dans la description.
Vous y trouverez également le minutage de
la vidéo,
qui vous permettra de la regarder partie par
partie.
Enfin,
je vous encourage aussi à écrire vos questions,
vos remarques,
vos suggestions,
vos compliments,
vos critiques,
ou vos insultes,
dans les commentaires.
Allez, c’est parti.
Prenez de quoi noter.
Mettez votre téléphone en mode avion,
et concentrez-vous.
Je rentre dans la dissertation.
Alors,
comme le ferait un correcteur,
je commence par me faire une impression générale
de la copie :
je la regarde rapidement
du début à la fin.
Je trouve que l’écriture n’est pas super
propre
— mais ça passe, c’est lisible.
Là,
je dois déjà m’arrêter,
parce qu’il y a déjà une chose qui me
choque.
Vous voyez de quoi je veux parler ?
L’introduction consiste en UN SEUL
et unique paragraphe.
Ça,
ça me donne déjà mal à la tête
— il faudrait quelqu’un pour me masser
les tempes
pendant que je lis.
Ça me donne déjà mal à la tête
parce que je sais que ça va être à moi
de faire l’effort
de distinguer les enjeux de l’introduction…
...alors qu’il aurait suffi à l’élève
de les distinguer visuellement.
C’est marrant,
parce que la semaine dernière,
un prof particulier m’a contacté à ce
propos.
Il m’a dit que selon un prof de prépa,
l’introduction devait tenir en un seul paragraphe,
et il a donc suggéré que j’avais tort
de dire aux élèves de faire plusieurs paragraphes
— puisque c’est un prof de prépa qui
l’a dit !
Je lui ai répondu que même si c’était
le président de la République qui l’avait
dit,
ça n’invaliderait pas ma consigne,
parce que sa pertinence est validée par l’expérience,
ET par la science.
Interrogez des lecteurs,
ils vous diront tous qu’ils préfèrent
lire un texte
subdivisé en paragraphes.
Et en effet,
les études scientifiques sur la lecture ont
montré
qu’un nouveau paragraphe offre un genre
de « respiration » à l’oeil.
En conclusion,
si vous voulez rendre la lecture de votre
copie moins pénible
— bah oui, parce que ce n’est pas un plaisir
pour le correcteur —
donc si vous voulez rendre la lecture de votre
copie moins pénible,
subdivisez votre introduction en paragraphes.
Si vous avez vraiment besoin d’être rassurés,
sachez que dans mon stock personnel,
j’ai beaucoup de copies de concours notées
18, 19, 20,
dans lesquelles l’introduction est subdivisée
en paragraphes.
Donc ma consigne est bonne :
subdivisez l’introduction de votre dissertation
en paragraphes,
et concentrez chaque paragraphe
exclusivement sur un enjeu précis de l’introduction.
Et si vous voulez savoir comment rédiger
une bonne introduction,
allez voir ma vidéo sur le sujet.
Je continue à descendre.
Moi,
ça me dérange vraiment qu’il n’y ait
pas de structure dans l’introduction.
Alors, je remarque déjà de gros défauts,
mais j’en parlerai lorsque j’analyserai
le développement dans le détail.
Ce qui est bien,
c’est que les paragraphes sont bien distincts
(pas comme dans l’introduction),
et que les références sont bien visibles.
3 paragraphes dans le grand I), c’est ce
qu’il faut.
Une conclusion partielle pour passer du grand
I) au grand II),
c’est bien.
Le grand II) ressemble au grand I),
donc c’est bien.
Ah,
là je ne vois pas pourquoi il a sauté une
ligne
— ce n’est pas grave,
mais c’est inutile.
Encore 3 paragraphes, c’est bien,
et puis ils sont de taille comparable.
La conclusion partielle pour passer du grand
II) au grand III),
ok.
Le grand III) ressemble au grand II),
donc c’est bien.
Le tout dernier paragraphe paraît un peu
plus court,
mais ce n’est pas choquant.
J’arrive à la conclusion.
Elle est de taille raisonnable (4 longues
phrases),
— mais tiens,
il a fait deux paragraphes !
Lol il rédige l’introduction,
la partie la plus importante de la dissertation,
il la rédige en un seul paragraphe,
et puis il subdivise la conclusion,
la partie la moins importante,
et la plus petite,
il la subdivise en deux paragraphes !
Ça montre bien que les élèves suivent souvent
des consignes qu’ils ne comprennent pas,
simplement pour obéir à un prof,
alors qu’il suffit de réfléchir à la
logique de la consigne.
Je vous le répète :
on ne crée pas des paragraphes pour obéir
aveuglément à un prof,
mais pour faciliter la lecture de votre lecteur,
c’est-à-dire de votre correcteur.
Si vous lui facilitez la tâche,
vous gagnez des points,
ou vous évitez d’en perdre.
Alors,
mon impression générale de la copie ?
Globalement positive :
la copie est assez propre,
elle est lisible,
et j’ai trouvé la plupart des indications
qu’on doit trouver dans une bonne copie.
Le développement a une structure classique
en trois fois trois paragraphes,
ce qui est sérieux.
Après,
je suis quand même déçu par le fait
que l’introduction tienne en un seul gros
bloc
— je sais déjà que je vais devoir faire
un effort
pour la lire attentivement.
Vous vous dites peut-être que j’exagère.
Oui,
vous avez raison si j’ai une seule dissertation
à corriger
— mais un correcteur doit en lire des dizaines,
voire une centaine !
Donc pour réussir
une dissertation de culture générale,
vous ne devez jamais oublier
la psychologie du correcteur.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
j’ai fait une vidéo sur ce sujet.
Bon,
maintenant que je me suis fait
une première impression globale de la copie,
il est temps de lire dans le détail
l’introduction de la dissertation.
C’est parti !
Première phrase de l’introduction :
« Dans Le disciple de Paul Bourget,
le comte André vit d’interminables heures
d’angoisse dans sa chambre d’hôtel
faisant face au tribunal. »
C’est parfait pour commencer :
la référence,
un roman français de la fin du XIXe siècle,
est noble et pertinente
(elle parle de la vérité judiciaire) ;
et puis la phrase est simple et efficace.
Je continue.
L’élève développe son accroche dans les
3 phrases suivantes.
Pourquoi pas,
mais c’est un peu long.
En tout cas,
c’est parfait sur le plan de l’expression
écrite :
c’est très clair,
fluide,
et je n’ai trouvé aucune faute.
Ces qualités sont cohérentes avec la note.
En revanche,
je n’aime pas la manière dont il passe
de l’accroche
à la suite de l’introduction :
« À l’image du comte André,
faut-il toujours préférer la vérité ? »
Ce n’est pas catastrophique,
mais c’est imparfait sur le plan de la méthodologie
— ce n’est pas le moment de poser le problème
dans la dissertation —
et c’est aussi imparfait sur le fond.
En effet,
le personnage de l’accroche, le comte André,
ne dit pas TOUJOURS la vérité
— il l’a juste préférée dans un cas
précis.
En termes de méthode,
l’élève aurait pu faire plus simple.
Une fois que vous avez développé votre accroche,
il suffit de justifier l’intérêt du sujet.
Il aurait pu écrire :
« Cet exemple nous invite à nous demander
s’il est toujours opportun de dire la vérité.
»
Je continue.
« Selon Zénon,
la vérité est caractérisée par l’universalité
et l’intemporalité. »
Bon, première chose :
là, il fallait évidemment créer un nouveau
paragraphe.
Nouvel enjeu (la définition des termes du
sujet),
donc nouveau paragraphe.
Deuxième remarque :
pourquoi est-ce qu’il cite un auteur
— qui plus est Zénon, un philosophe assez
peu connu antérieur à Socrate —
pourquoi est-ce qu’il cite un tel auteur
pour définir la notion cardinale du sujet
?
Ce n’était pas nécessaire.
Troisième remarque :
c’est quoi cette pseudo-définition ?
C’est bien trop vague :
il donne simplement 2 caractéristiques du
concept de vérité
— je ne vois pas à quoi ça sert ici.
Si vous voulez définir simplement le concept
de vérité,
dites que c’est la correspondance entre
un énoncé et un fait.
Bien sûr,
on pourrait développer cette définition,
mais ce n’est pas l’enjeu dans une introduction
de dissertation.
Pour ma quatrième remarque, je relis la phrase
:
« Selon Zénon,
la vérité est caractérisée par l’universalité
et l’intemporalité. »
c’est tout ce qu’il nous donne comme élément
de définition,
parce qu’il enchaîne directement sur la
problématisation
avec la phrase suivante :
« Préférer en toute circonstance la vérité,
c’est donc privilégier la quête de la
vérité à toutes les autres recherches
comme celle des plaisirs. »
C’est le PREMIER VRAI défaut de la copie
:
l’élève ne définit pas sérieusement
les termes du sujet.
En l’occurrence, il suffisait de définir
efficacement le concept de vérité,
parce que les autres mots sont des termes
communs
qui ne posent aucun problème de sens.
J’en profite pour faire un rappel de méthodologie
:
vous devez impérativement définir les termes
du sujet dans l’introduction.
Comme pour la question de la subdivision de
l’introduction en paragraphes,
des élèves me disent que leur prof leur
INTERDIT
de définir les termes du sujet dans l’introduction
— mais je leur réponds la même chose qu’à
ceux
qui m’interrogent sur la structure de l’introduction
:
même si leur prof est Bac+50, il a tort,
parce que c’est la logique même
qui prescrit de définir les termes du sujet.
Quand vous manipulez un objet matériel,
vous avez besoin de le voir précisément
— par exemple,
vous ne cuisinez pas avec un bandeau sur les
yeux
(en tout cas, moi non) —
eh bien c’est pareil pour un objet intellectuel,
vous avez besoin de le voir PRÉCISÉMENT
pour le manipuler.
Or,
voir précisément un concept,
eh bien c’est LE DÉFINIR.
Avant de manipuler le concept de vérité,
de le connecter à d’autres concepts,
de le confronter à des hypothèses et d’en
tirer des conclusions,
il faut donc LE DÉFINIR.
Et comme pour la question des paragraphes
dans l’introduction,
j’ajoute que les termes sont définis en
introduction
dans plein de bonnes et de très bonnes copies
de concours.
Donc il n’y a pas à réfléchir :
définissez clairement les termes du sujet
dans l’introduction de la dissertation de
culture générale.
Voilà pour le rappel de méthodologie,
je reviens à nos moutons.
L’élève a mal défini le concept de vérité,
puis il est passé à la problématisation.
Je veux faire une autre remarque,
sur le fond maintenant.
Relisez bien les 2 phrases :
« Selon Zénon,
la vérité est caractérisée par l’universalité
et l’intemporalité. »
« Préférer en toute circonstance la vérité,
c’est DONC privilégier la quête de la
vérité à toutes les autres recherches
comme celle des plaisirs. »
Vous êtes au courant que « DONC »,
c’est un lien logique de conséquence.
MAIS en quoi « privilégier la quête de
la vérité à toutes les autres recherches
» c’est une conséquence de « la vérité
est caractérisée par l’universalité et
l’intemporalité. » ?!
Bah en rien.
L’élève a donc créé une FAUSSE connexion
logique ;
il a arnaqué le lecteur
— enfin le correcteur, pas moi.
Il n’y a en réalité aucun lien logique
entre les deux idées
— mais il dit explicitement que la seconde
est la conséquence de la première.
Ça, c’est un peu la spécialité des élèves
de Sciences Po.
En pratique,
ça passe, parce que les correcteurs lisent
très rapidement les copies
— mais c’est quand même risqué.
Si vous le faites à chaque phrase,
le correcteur s’en rendra compte
— or il n’est pas maso,
il n’aime pas qu’on l’arnaque.
Mieux vaut donc manipuler HONNÊTEMENT des
idées simples
et les connecter selon leurs VÉRITABLES liens.
En l’occurrence,
l’élève aurait simplement dû créer un
nouveau paragraphe —
revenir à la ligne, faire un alinéa, et
se passer de lien logique.
Ce n’est pas grave s’il n’y a pas de
connexion logique entre l’accroche et la
définition des termes.
Je continue.
L’élève développe la problématisation
sur 3 phrases.
Je les lis rapidement :
« Mais c’est aussi dire la vérité en
toute circonstance et préférer la vérité
au mensonge. Il semble qu’il faille rechercher
et dire la vérité en toute circonstance
car la vérité est le seul bien aimable et
est nécessaire à la stabilité de la société.
Mais une telle attitude systématique peut
menacer notre bonheur et nous conduire à
faire le mal. »
Bon, dans l’ensemble c’est plutôt efficace.
Il dit grosso modo : on peut préférer ATTEINDRE
la vérité plutôt qu’autre chose ;
on peut aussi préférer DIRE la vérité,
plutôt que la taire ou la dissimuler ;
en effet, la vérité est une bonne chose
et la société en a besoin pour fonctionner
;
mais c’est peut-être dangereux de TOUJOURS
préférer la vérité.
Sur le fond, ça se tient : c’est un petit
raisonnement pertinent.
Sur la forme, c’est bon aussi : c’est
toujours très clair et fluide
— même si je trouve qu’il aurait pu éviter
les répétitions de « vérité »
et « en toute circonstance ».
Après ces 3 phrases de développement de
la problématisation,
il pose une question :
« Alors une telle morale fondée sur la préférence
absolue pour la vérité
peut-elle guider les hommes ? »
J’imagine que c’est la problématique.
Encore une fois, ça aurait été plus clair
en créant un nouveau paragraphe
— je n’aurais pas eu à essayer de deviner
l’intention de l’élève.
Alors, la question est plutôt claire,
mais comme il a déjà répété l’idée
de la préférence de la vérité dans les
phrases précédentes, il aurait pu écrire
plus simplement :
« Une telle morale peut-elle guider les hommes
? »
Comparons la problématique avec l’énoncé
:
la question du sujet c’est « Faut-il toujours
préférer la vérité ? »,
et la problématique c’est « La morale
fondée sur la préférence absolue pour la
vérité peut-elle guider les hommes ? ».
Les deux questions expriment le même problème
intellectuel,
et c’est bien normal parce que ce problème
est transparent dans l’énoncé.
Du point de vue méthodologique,
lorsque le sujet est une question, il suffit
la plupart du temps
de reformuler l’énoncé pour rédiger la
problématique.
Je continue.
Après la question de la problématique,
il annonce le plan.
Encore une fois, ça aurait été plus clair
en créant un nouveau paragraphe.
Lisons son plan :
« Dans un premier temps, nous montrerons
qu’il est nécessaire de toujours préférer
la vérité mais nous verrons dans un second
temps qu’une telle morale est inapplicable.
Enfin, à quelles conditions faut-il privilégier
la vérité ? »
Donc son plan, c’est :
1ère idée : il faut toujours préférer
la vérité ;
2ème idée : mais en fait ce n’est pas
possible ;
3ème « idée » : du coup quand est-ce qu’il
faut préférer la vérité ?
Je ne vais pas critiquer le plan à partir
du concept de vérité,
parce que ça ne va pas vous servir à grand-chose
pour vos dissertations
— je vais critiquer le plan du point de
vue de la méthodologie.
Le 1er défaut,
c’est que l’idée du grand I) et celle
du grand II) sont incompatibles.
Grand I : il faut toujours préférer la vérité.
Grand II : ah non, en fait ce n’est pas
possible.
Or, le deuxième élément de réponse n’est
pas censé invalider totalement le premier,
mais le dépasser en l’incluant.
C’est-à-dire que la première idée doit
rester vraie dans une certaine mesure,
et la deuxième idée approfondit la question
avec une hypothèse plus probable.
Pour corriger le défaut du plan de l’élève,
il faut introduire de la nuance.
Pour le grand I), il aurait par exemple pu
écrire « La préférence pour la vérité
semble tout d’abord ne pas devoir admettre
d’exception. ».
Grâce au verbe « sembler », je montre bien
qu’on est au niveau de l’apparence.
Pour le grand II), il aurait pu écrire « Une
morale fondée sur cette préférence absolue
rencontrerait toutefois des limites dans la
pratique. »
Sur le fond, je suis moins radical que lui
:
je ne dis pas que la morale en question est
inapplicable,
j'émets simplement l’hypothèse qu’on
ne pourra pas l’appliquer parfaitement.
Le 2ème défaut de son annonce de plan,
c’est le grand III).
Déjà, ce n’est pas un élément de réponse,
c’est une question.
Et puis, cette question rappelle grosso modo
le problème de la dissertation
— parce qu’on se doute bien qu’on ne
peut pas TOUJOURS préférer la vérité,
et que donc le problème intellectuel,
c’est de savoir QUAND on doit préférer
la vérité.
En fait, c’est comme s’il n’avait pas
fait de grand III)
— on verra plus tard dans le développement
s’il propose une vraie idée qui dépasse
les deux premières du plan.
Enfin, le 3ème défaut de son annonce de
plan,
c’est l’expression écrite.
Il faut au moins une virgule avant le lien
logique d’opposition « mais »,
parce qu’on a besoin de respirer en lisant
la phrase.
Moi je diviserais cette phrase en deux :
« Dans un premier temps, nous montrerons
qu’il est nécessaire de toujours préférer
la vérité. [POINT] Nous verrons dans un
second temps [D’AILLEURS ICI IL FAUT DIRE
DEUXIÈME TEMPS, ET NON PAS SECOND, PARCE
QU’IL Y A UN 3ÈME TEMPS] nous verrons dans
un deuxième temps qu’une telle morale est
CEPENDANT [j’ajoute un lien logique pour
signaler l’opposition entre les 2 idées]
une telle morale est CEPENDANT inapplicable.
»
Dans l’ensemble, l’annonce de plan est
plutôt efficace
— mais quand même, on attend mieux d’une
copie notée 20/20.
Si je devais reprendre son annonce de plan,
j’écrirais :
« Nous montrerons tout d’abord que la préférence
pour la vérité semble ne pas devoir admettre
d’exception. Nous verrons ensuite qu’une
morale reposant sur cette préférence absolue
rencontrerait toutefois des limites dans la
pratique. Nous terminerons donc par chercher
des critères qui puissent fonder une éthique
de la vérité. »
Encore une fois, ce n’est pas MON plan
— c’est la manière dont je reformulerais
son annonce de plan.
Voilà, c’est bon pour l’introduction.
Je vais maintenant jeter un oeil à la conclusion.
Comme je l’ai dit,
c’est bien inutile de subdiviser la conclusion
en 2 paragraphes.
Alors, je regarde le premier.
Les 2 phrases rappellent les éléments de
réponse à la problématique,
donc c’est ok.
Je passe au second paragraphe.
Voilà c’est ce que je craignais
— ah non c’est même pire !
L’élève commet 2 erreurs :
dans la 1ère phrase, il cite une référence
;
et dans la 2nde, il fait une ouverture.
Ça ne sert à rien de citer Rousseau dans
la conclusion,
parce qu’on est sorti de l’argumentation.
Et puis terminer la conclusion par une ouverture,
je le déconseille pour les raisons suivantes
:
vous risquez de souligner une idée qui aurait
mérité de figurer dans le développement
(et du coup vous mettez en évidence une faille
dans votre argumentation…) ;
vous risquez d’évoquer une idée banale
ou maladroite ;
c’est très compliqué à réaliser
et bien sûr on ne vous donne pas de consignes
précises ;
ça demande une maîtrise de la discipline
et une maturité intellectuelle propres à
un prof,
pas à un élève ;
et comme c’est à la toute fin de l’épreuve,
vous manquez probablement de temps.
Là, en l’occurrence,
il souligne une idée intéressante,
qui avait donc sa place dans le développement
:
il faut préférer la vérité pour rester
digne.
Voilà, ce que vous devez retenir pour la
conclusion de la dissertation, c’est :
pas de référence ni d’ouverture ;
contentez-vous de synthétiser les résultats
de la réflexion.
Ça y est,
on en a fini avec l’introduction et la conclusion.
Je sais,
c’était long
— mais encore une fois,
l’introduction est la partie
la plus importante de la dissertation,
donc c’est normal qu’on y passe du temps.
Alors, quoi conclure ?
Je trouve qu’il y a deux défauts principaux,
et deux qualités principales.
Le premier défaut,
c’est le paragraphe unique
qui rend la lecture difficile
(j’en ai déjà beaucoup parlé).
Le second défaut,
c’est la mauvaise définition des termes.
Maintenant,
la première qualité
de l’introduction de la dissertation,
c’est la clarté du propos.
L’élève manipule des idées qu’il maîtrise.
Il comprend ce qu’il dit,
et moi aussi.
Et je comprends d’autant mieux
que l’expression écrite est efficace
— ça c’est la seconde qualité.
Pour l’instant,
le style est très clair.
Il n’y a ni maladresses,
ni fautes.
Manifestement,
c’est un élève qui écrit bien.
Et ça,
c’est un vrai atout en dissertation,
parce que la clarté du style est SURVALORISÉE.
À fond égal,
un 4-5
se transforme en 7-8,
un 8 en 11-12,
un 15 en 18-19-20.
Vous verrez que cette copie
en est un bon exemple.
Donc pour résumer,
deux défauts :
le paragraphe unique
et l’absence de définition satisfaisante
;
et deux qualités :
l’efficacité du propos
et celle du style.
Quant à la conclusion,
l’élève se prend la tête pour rien
— il essaie d’impressionner le correcteur,
mais ça ne change pas grand-chose.
À ce stade de la correction,
l’introduction me fait plutôt bonne impression
— mais c’est quand même loin d’être
parfait.
Si j’étais le correcteur,
je me dirais que je vais noter la copie
entre 13 et 17
— je déciderai de la note finale
en lisant le développement.
Bon, allez du coup,
on y va.
Je ne vais pas lire le développement dans
le détail,
mais en diagonale, comme le ferait un correcteur.
Je vais me concentrer sur les arguments,
les références, et les transitions.
Let’s go.
Bon,
ça commence TRÈS TRÈS mal…
C’est quand même fou qu’un correcteur
mette 20/20 à une copie dans laquelle
l’élève cite une référence dès la première
phrase du développement !
Le 2ème mot, c’est le nom d’un auteur
!
Si j’étais le correcteur,
je me dirais déjà que je ne pourrais pas
lui mettre plus de 12-13.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu’en commençant son développement
par « Pour Saint Augustin, blablabla... », il
révèle qu’il ne sait pas ce qu’est une
dissertation.
Tiens, qu’est-ce qu’une dissertation ?
C’est un exercice d’ARGUMENTATION.
Le but,
c’est d’apporter des éléments de réponse
intelligents à un problème INTELLECTUEL.
Vous devez convaincre le lecteur de la pertinence
de votre propos en présentant des arguments,
c’est-à-dire des idées précises.
Les références servent uniquement À L’INTÉRIEUR
des paragraphes,
EN SOUTIEN des arguments,
pour leur apporter du crédit grâce à l’autorité
intellectuelle de l’auteur
(si vous citez un ouvrage).
Bref, là c’est catastrophique : moi j’aurais
biffé cette phrase.
En plus, il mentionne de nouveau Saint Augustin
une phrase plus tard !
Si je devais corriger ce départ raté, j’écrirais
: « En premier lieu, les hommes tendent à
investir la vérité d’une valeur suprême.
»
J’expliquerais ensuite cette idée en quelques
phrases,
et c’est seulement APRÈS que je ferais
référence à Saint Augustin
pour étayer mon argument.
Autre défaut de ce premier paragraphe, l’élève
cite une deuxième référence.
Ce n’est pas rédhibitoire, mais c’est
une mauvaise décision.
En effet, je vous recommande d’utiliser
une seule et unique référence par paragraphe.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que je suis pragmatique.
En vous concentrant sur une seule et unique
référence,
vous avez plus de chance de choisir la meilleure
par rapport à l’argument ;
vous avez aussi plus de chance de la mobiliser
intelligemment ;
et enfin vous ne risquez pas de donner au
correcteur
l’impression que vous faites du name dropping.
Là, en citant la seconde référence,
l’élève commet une erreur logique avec
le lien d’illustration « Ainsi ».
Il dit que la vérité n’est pas soumise
au temps,
puis il prétend illustrer cette idée en
évoquant un personnage
qui hésite à abandonner la quête de la
vérité.
Vous voyez le problème ?
Idée : la vérité n’est pas soumise au
temps.
Exemple : ce mec hésite à abandonner la
recherche de la vérité.
En réalité, les 2 idées sont déconnectées.
MAIS l’élève voulait citer Voltaire, donc
il a encore arnaqué le correcteur !
Qui manifestement n’est pas à ça près…
Bref, ce que vous devez retenir,
c’est que vous améliorerez vos chances
de décrocher une bonne note
en vous concentrant sur une seule et unique
référence
dans chaque paragraphe du développement.
Après ce rappel de méthodologie,
je passe au 2ème paragraphe.
Là, l’élève commence bien par un argument
:
« De plus, il faut toujours préférer la
vérité au mensonge. »
La phrase est très efficace.
Elle est courte, très claire, et elle contient
les mots importants de l’énoncé :
le nom commun « vérité » et l’adverbe
« toujours ».
Je lui reproche une seule chose : elle manque
de nuance.
J’écrirais plutôt « On devrait encore
préférer la vérité au mensonge. »
En dissertation, il vaut mieux s’exprimer
avec modération,
à la fois pour éviter de rendre les idées
incompatibles
— ce que l’élève a fait dans son plan
—
et aussi pour éveiller la tolérance du correcteur.
Je reviens au 2ème paragraphe.
L’élève développe son argument dans la
deuxième phrase,
puis il introduit une référence.
Ce n’est pas aussi tôt que dans le 1er
paragraphe, mais c’est encore un tôt.
Il aurait pu développer davantage l’idée
de son argument.
Et puis l’introduction de la référence
(« Pour John Stuart Mill dans L’Utilitarisme...
»)
est maladroite.
Il fallait plutôt écrire « John Stuart
Mill explique dans L’Utilitarisme que la
confiance etc... », ou bien citer la référence
entre parenthèses après le nom de l’auteur.
C’est un détail, mais les très bonnes
copies ne font pas ce genre d’erreur.
Dans la suite du paragraphe, l’élève introduit
une autre référence
— je vous ai déjà expliqué pourquoi c’est
une mauvaise décision.
Ici, en plus, l’exemple n’est pas très
pertinent, puisqu’il montre que le mensonge
dégrade la confiance nécessaire à l’intimité,
alors que l’argument de Mill, c’est que
le mensonge dégrade la confiance nécessaire
à la coopération — ce n’est pas la même
chose.
Comme je vous l’ai expliqué en commentant
le 1er paragraphe,
plus vous mobilisez de références,
plus vous risquez de manipuler MALADROITEMENT
les idées.
Je passe au 3ème paragraphe.
Alors,
je trouve l’argument plutôt efficace :
« Enfin, la vérité doit toujours être
préférée car elle est bénéfique pour
autrui. »
Ce qui est bien, c’est qu’on comprend
immédiatement l’idée.
On sait aussi qu’elle est pertinente,
parce que l’élève reprend l’expression
de l’énoncé, « toujours préférer la
vérité ».
Ça c’est une bonne habitude que vous pouvez
prendre :
pour persuader le correcteur de la pertinence
de votre argumentation,
vous reprenez systématiquement les termes
clés de l’énoncé dans les arguments,
et vous les saupoudrez également dans le
paragraphe.
Là c’est fait un peu grossièrement, mais
ça reste efficace
— pas besoin de faire dans la subtilité
pour réussir une dissertation.
En fait, je lui reproche une seule chose à
cette phrase,
c’est de ne pas nuancer l’idée : « la
vérité DOIT TOUJOURS être préférée »…
« elle EST bénéfique pour autrui ».
Ensuite, l’élève développe l’argument
en une seule phrase
— c’est encore une fois trop rapide —
puis il introduit la référence avec une
phrase très efficace :
« Dans la IVe promenade des Rêveries du
promeneur solitaire,
Rousseau distingue la vérité abstraite de
la vérité particulière. »
Et dans ce dernier paragraphe du grand I),
il commet ENCORE l’erreur d’introduire
une seconde référence.
Il évoque le Discours de la méthode de Descartes
en une seule phrase,
ce qui est vraiment du name dropping.
Tiens, j’en profite pour faire une petite
pub pour mon site :
si vous voulez savoir ce qu’il y a dans
le Discours de la méthode de Descartes,
qui est un bouquin vraiment fondamental dans
l’histoire de la pensée,
eh bien j’ai écrit un résumé détaillé
très clair sur mon blog.
Vous allez sur 1000 idées de culture générale,
vous écrivez « Discours de la méthode » dans
la barre de recherche,
et vous le trouverez.
Je reviens au dernier paragraphe du grand
I).
Sur le plan de la rédaction, il n’est pas
top.
Il y a trop de répétitions :
« vérité », « car », « donc ».
Et il y a aussi 2 fautes :
un S incompréhensible à « En effet »,
et « bannir » qui s’écrit B - A - 2N
- I - R.
Je descends un peu,
et j’arrive à la transition entre le grand
I) et le grand II),
ce que j’appelle une « conclusion partielle
».
Comment le candidat s’y prend-il ?
La 1ère phrase rappelle l’idée générale
du grand I).
La 2ème rappelle l’objection qui amène
l’idée générale du grand II).
Et l’élève termine par une question qui
tease un peu le grand II).
C’est carré et clair : c’est très efficace.
Après, moi, je vous conseille de vous passer
de la question,
parce que c’est plus difficile à rédiger.
Les 2 premières phrases suffisent.
Alors,
qu’est-ce que je peux dire sur le grand
un ?
En synthèse,
j’ai quand même été déçu :
que l’élève commence un paragraphe par
une référence,
ça me choque ;
qu’il en mobilise deux par paragraphe,
ça me dérange ;
et puis forcément,
il ne développe pas assez les références.
Après,
il faut reconnaître que ce grand un a des
qualités :
les arguments sont pertinents ;
le propos est structuré ;
le style est efficace ;
et j’ajoute que les références,
à la fois philosophiques et littéraires,
les références sont bonnes.
Mais bon,
de là à mettre vingt sur vingt…
Je me dis que le paquet de copies
devait vraiment être mauvais…
En plus, le sujet n’était pas difficile.
Bon, allez,
on se plonge dans le grand deux.
Si c’était la copie d’un élève de ma
formation, je m’énerverais.
Non mais comment est-ce qu’on peut commencer
un paragraphe de dissertation en écrivant
« Tout d’abord, pour Nietzsche, il est
dangereux de toujours préférer la vérité.
» ?!
Je vous en ai déjà parlé, mais je le répète
:
ne faites surtout pas ça !
Un paragraphe de dissertation commence par
UN ARGUMENT.
En l’occurrence, il suffisait d’écrire
:
« Préférer systématiquement la vérité
peut s’avérer dangereux. »
Mon argument est court, très clair ;
je reprends les termes clés de l’énoncé
(j’ai remplacé l’adverbe « toujours
» par « systématiquement ») ;
et je présente l’idée comme une hypothèse.
Je reviens au texte de l’élève.
Regardez sa 2ème phrase :
« Dans Volonté de puissance,
Nietzsche décrit le monde comme un chaos
de forces mouvantes
qui n’admet aucune fixité. »
Quel est le lien avec la phrase précédente
?
Bah il n’y en a aucun.
Le candidat recrache simplement son cours.
Après, ce qui est bien,
c’est qu’il développe la référence
sur plusieurs phrases
(quatre, précisément).
Mais il REFAIT l’erreur de mobiliser une
seconde référence !
S’il avait commencé son paragraphe par
un argument
et s’il avait expliqué un peu l’idée
de cet argument,
il n’aurait pas eu besoin d’une référence
supplémentaire.
Et puis l’introduction de cette seconde
référence est trop abrupte.
Il faut accompagner le lecteur : l’élève
aurait dû lui expliquer plus clairement
pourquoi on se met à parler d’un roman
de Balzac maintenant.
Il aurait par exemple pu écrire tout simplement
:
« Balzac donne vie à cette idée dans Le
Père Goriot. »
Sinon, encore une fois, la référence est
balayée en 2 phrases
— c’est trop rapide.
Sur le plan de la rédaction,
on retrouve les mêmes défauts que dans le
grand I).
Trop de répétitions :
« Nietzsche » apparaît 4 fois en 6 phrases
!
Et « vérité » apparaît 6 fois !
Ça manque aussi de nuance.
Allez, je passe au paragraphe suivant.
Là on a affaire à un véritable argument
:
« De plus, dire la vérité en toutes circonstances
peut également faire du mal. »
C’est une idée pertinente ;
il n’y a pas de référence ;
et le verbe « pouvoir » apporte de la modération.
Ce qui n’est pas super, c’est la répétition
du lien logique d’addition :
« De plus » et « également »
— moi j’aurais écrit uniquement « également
»
(« Dire la vérité en toutes circonstances
peut ÉGALEMENT faire du mal. »).
Et par ailleurs l’expression « faire du
mal » n’est pas terrible,
elle est trop vague.
J’aurais dit plus précisément que « la
vérité peut blesser autrui ».
Je continue.
Le candidat développe l’idée de l’argument
sur 2 phrases — c’est bien.
Il introduit ensuite un exemple littéraire
qu’il développe jusqu’à la fin,
donc c’est très bien.
Le style est toujours aussi efficace.
C’est le MEILLEUR paragraphe depuis le début.
Si tous les autres avaient suivi ce modèle,
j’aurais pu comprendre que le correcteur
mette 20 sur 20.
Petit détail : ça ce sont des guillemets
anglais ;
or, vous devez utiliser des guillemets français
— parce que vous écrivez... en français.
Allez, je regarde le dernier paragraphe.
Je l’ai déjà dit au tout début :
je ne vois pas pourquoi il a sauté une ligne
— il faut rester cohérent,
c’est-à-dire appliquer les mêmes choix
tout au long de la copie.
Ce paragraphe commence lui aussi par un véritable
argument :
« Enfin, il ne faut pas toujours préférer
la vérité
car elle peut menacer la stabilité sociale.
»
C’est clair et nuancé, donc c’est bien.
Après, on pourrait faire plus court, par
exemple :
« Préférer toujours la vérité peut menacer
la stabilité sociale. »
Je trouve aussi que le candidat ne varie pas
assez son vocabulaire :
comme pour le grand I),
il commence le dernier paragraphe par « enfin
»
— c’est certes efficace, mais ça fait
un peu mécanique.
Et puis comme dans le 2ème paragraphe de
ce grand II),
il modère l’idée avec le verbe « pouvoir
».
À la place, il aurait pu utiliser le conditionnel
:
« Préférer toujours la vérité menacerait
la stabilité sociale. »
Mais bon, dans l’ensemble, l’argument
reste efficace
— et puis maintenant qu’on lit de vrais
arguments,
on ne va pas se plaindre !
Je continue à analyser ce paragraphe.
Le candidat développe l’argument sur 2
phrases.
Il remarque intelligemment qu’il a affirmé
le contraire dans le grand I) :
« Pourtant, nous avons établi en première
partie... ».
C’est pour éviter ce problème qu’il
faut modérer les arguments
— sinon on se contredit.
On présente des HYPOTHÈSES dans une grande
partie,
comme ça on peut dire dans une autre grande
partie
qu’il existe aussi des raisons qui rendent
les hypothèses contraires crédibles.
Là, en l’occurrence, il suffisait de dire
que la vérité contribue à la stabilité
sociale dans certains cas,
et qu’elle y nuit dans d’autres.
Donc jouez la sécurité, préférez la nuance.
Je reviens au texte.
L’introduction de la référence,
« Pour Pascal dans ses Trois discours sur
la condition des grands... »,
est maladroite.
Il faut écrire « Pascal affirme dans ses
Trois discours sur la condition des grands
que blablabla »,
ou bien « Pascal considère que la cohésion
sociale blablabla... »
et mettre le titre entre parenthèses à la
fin.
En revanche,
le candidat développe la référence jusqu’à
la fin :
c’est une bonne chose.
Je rappelle qu’il faut utiliser des guillemets
français.
Je descends et j’arrive à la conclusion
partielle du grand II).
La 1ère phrase rappelle l’idée de la grande
partie,
puis 2 questions teasent la grande partie
suivante.
Ce n’est pas la méthode que je recommande,
mais c’est suffisant
— inutile de se prendre davantage la tête.
Alors, que conclure du grand deux ?
Cette grande partie a très mal commencé,
mais j’ai enfin lu de vrais paragraphes,
avec un argument développé,
puis soutenu,
dans un second temps,
par une référence,
elle-même développée.
En termes d’organisation des idées,
je pense que j’aurais TERMINÉ
par celle qu’il a présentée en premier,
parce que c’est la moins évidente.
J’aurais donc commencé en disant
que la vérité peut blesser autrui ;
j’aurais enchaîné en disant
qu’elle peut nuire à la stabilité sociale
;
et j’aurais terminé en expliquant
qu’on peut aussi concevoir la vérité
comme l’expression d’une morale inférieure.
Comme ça,
mon raisonnement progresse
de l’idée la plus évidente à la moins
évidente
— c’est l’ordre de présentation des
idées
le plus efficace en dissertation.
Sinon,
le style est toujours aussi efficace.
Les liens logiques sont toujours les mêmes
:
« tout d’abord »,
« de plus »,
« enfin »,
« en effet »,
« car »,
« donc »
— il n’y a quasiment que ça.
MAIS c’est suffisant pour réussir une dissertation.
Comme dans le grand un,
les références sont bonnes
— et elles sont à la fois philosophiques
et littéraires.
Je remarque tout de même
qu’il n’y a aucune référence originale
pour l’instant
— il n’y a aucune « pépite »,
comme disent certains correcteurs —
et ce n’est pas très cohérent avec la
note.
MAIS BON, je vous l’ai dit depuis le début,
cette copie a été surnotée.
En conclusion,
ce grand deux est meilleur que le grand un.
Allez,
on passe au grand trois.
Alors, 1ère phrase du grand III) :
« Tout d’abord, le sujet doit faire preuve
de prudence
afin de bien décider lorsqu’il doit préférer
la vérité. »
Bon, déjà c’est un véritable argument
— le candidat a pris le pli.
Il était peut-être stressé au début de
la dissertation :
il pensait au correcteur
et il se disait « Il faut que je lui donne
sa dose ».
La grande partie commence encore par « tout
d’abord »
— mais bon, la structure est simple et explicite,
donc c’est efficace.
En revanche, l’argument, qui porte sur la
prudence,
manque lui-même de prudence.
Mieux vaut écrire par exemple
« La prudence semble nécessaire pour décider
si la vérité est opportune. »
L’élève, lui, a répété le verbe « devoir
».
Ensuite il introduit directement une référence
— c’est bien sûr trop tôt.
Et en plus, il ne consacre que 2 phrases à
la référence.
Comme dans le grand I) et dans le grand II),
il introduit une seconde référence.
Encore une fois, je préciserais, pour le
confort du lecteur,
que la référence illustre l’idée que
je viens d’évoquer.
J’écrirais par exemple « Marguerite Yourcenar
illustre le rôle de la prudence à l’égard
de la vérité dans Les mémoires d’Hadrien.
».
Sinon, le développement de la référence
est intéressant.
Moi, je me serais passé de citer Aristote
;
j’aurais d’abord expliqué avec mes propres
mots
en quoi il peut être nécessaire d’anticiper
les effets de la révélation de la vérité,
puis j’aurais illustré cette idée
en développant davantage la référence aux
Mémoires d’Hadrien.
La dernière phrase du paragraphe est efficace
(pour rappeler l’argument),
mais encore une fois, je modérerais l’idée
— et cela d’autant plus que l’argument
suivant soutient une hypothèse différente
!
J’écrirais plutôt :
« L’homme aurait donc intérêt à être
pragmatique dans son rapport à la vérité.
».
En effet, l’idée du 1er argument,
c’est de dire qu’il faut préférer la
vérité en analysant ses potentiels effets
;
celle du 2ème argument,
c’est qu’il faut la préférer en analysant
l’intention.
Je clarifie :
1er argument : si les effets potentiels sont
bons, il faut dire la vérité.
2ème argument : si l’intention est bonne,
il faut la dire.
Ce sont des idées bien différentes.
Donc encore une fois,
il faut présenter les arguments avec modération
pour éviter de donner l’impression qu’on
se contredit.
Je reviens au texte.
Comme dans le premier paragraphe,
l’élève commence par un vrai argument
:
« De plus, le sujet doit privilégier la
vérité lorsque son intention vise le Bien.
» ;
puis il enchaîne immédiatement avec une
référence
— qu’il introduit maladroitement :
« Pour Kant dans La critique de la raison
pratique... ».
Il fallait plutôt écrire
« Kant avance dans La critique de la raison
pratique que blablabla ».
L’argument est plutôt efficace, mais on
retrouve encore les mêmes défauts :
toujours le même lien logique ;
pas de modération.
Il ne consacre que 2 phrases à la référence,
puis il en introduit une seconde.
En revanche, cette fois-ci, il le fait intelligemment
et il pense à son lecteur :
il reprend un exemple passé sous un nouvel
angle ;
et il dit explicitement que l’exemple sert
à illustrer l’idée qu’il vient d’évoquer.
« L’exemple d’A. de Maulincour dans Ferragus
doit donc être réévalué
à la lumière de ce nouveau critère. »
C’est beaucoup plus facile à lire, c’est
fluide.
Il développe un peu l’exemple, puis il
rappelle l’idée du paragraphe
— on peut remarquer qu’il la présente
avec nuance : « SEMBLE ÊTRE un bon guide
».
Cette formulation apporte un peu d’air frais
parce que le candidat utilise beaucoup les
verbes « devoir » et « pouvoir »
depuis le début de la dissertation.
Sur le plan du style, c’est globalement
efficace,
mais je note qu’il y a encore trop de répétitions
:
par exemple « sujet » ou « circonstance
».
Allez, on passe au tout dernier paragraphe
de la dissertation.
Je lis l’argument :
« Enfin, la vérité doit être préférée
si et seulement si
le sujet a mené un travail philosophique
suffisant pour en mesurer la pureté. »
C’est un véritable argument.
En revanche, c’est un peu hors-sujet sur
le fond,
parce que l’élève dit « Il faut préférer
la vérité SI c’est vraiment la vérité.
»
Or, le problème c’est de savoir s’il
faut toujours préférer la vérité
EN PARTANT DU PRINCIPE que c’est la vérité
vraie, comme on dit.
Mais bon, je ne suis pas censé parler du
fond.
Sur la forme, la phrase est plutôt efficace
: on comprend facilement l’idée.
Après, il y a toujours les mêmes défauts
:
le dernier paragraphe commence encore par
« enfin »
— je ne lui demande pas de faire du Proust,
mais ça serait bien de varier un peu.
Et du coup 20 sur 20, ce n’est pas mérité.
Autre défaut récurrent :
le manque de modération, dont sont responsables
le verbe « devoir »
et la locution mathématique « si et seulement
si ».
Enfin, la phrase est un peu longue pour être
un argument.
J’aurais par exemple formulé l’idée
de la manière suivante :
« Il paraît encore nécessaire d’estimer
la pureté de la vérité avant de la préférer.
».
Je regarde la suite du paragraphe.
Le candidat introduit encore une fois la référence
à la deuxième phrase
— c’est-à-dire bien trop tôt.
Ce qui est bien, c’est qu’il la développe.
Sur la forme, il y a encore les mêmes défauts
que dans les paragraphes précédents.
Trop de répétitions :
« vérité » apparaît 8 fois en 7 phrases
et « Foucault » 3 fois.
Ce n’est pas très grave,
mais ces imperfections de style devraient
retenir le correcteur de donner 20 sur 20.
Autre détail : les guillemets anglais.
Après, l’expression écrite reste efficace,
notamment grâce aux liens logiques.
Voilà pour le grand III).
Pour conclure mon commentaire,
je vais reprendre la méthode que j’applique
pour corriger les copies des élèves de ma
formation :
je vais vous donner les trois principaux défauts,
puis les trois principales qualités de la
dissertation
— et enfin,
je vous dirai quelle note j’aurais donnée
à cette copie.
Alors,
le plus gros défaut de la copie,
c’est l’introduction.
Vous vous souvenez,
elle est d’un seul bloc
— ce qui la rend pénible à lire —
et elle n’est pas idéale
du point de vue de la méthodologie.
Après,
on est d’accord,
il y a pire
— mais bon,
vingt sur vingt,
encore une fois c’est surnoté.
Ensuite,
le deuxième principal défaut,
c’est l’expression de l’argumentation
— et je dis bien « l’expression »,
parce que les arguments,
les idées en elles-mêmes,
elles sont plutôt pertinentes.
Mais vous vous souvenez,
à de nombreuses reprises,
l’élève commence directement le paragraphe
par une référence
— or ça,
c’est rédhibitoire.
On ne peut pas donner vingt
à un candidat qui n’a pas parfaitement
compris
ce qu’est une dissertation.
Enfin,
troisième défaut principal,
la gestion des références.
Je l’ai répété dans mon commentaire :
c’est une mauvaise idée de mobiliser plusieurs
références
dans un même paragraphe.
Et puis dans cette copie,
ça confine au name dropping.
Une référence ne doit apparaître qu’au
tiers
ou à la moitié du paragraphe,
une fois que vous avez présenté
et expliqué votre argument
— c’est alors que vous pouvez vous servir
d’une autorité extérieure
pour donner plus de crédit à votre argument.
De ce point de vue,
cette copie n’est pas bonne.
Voilà pour les trois principaux défauts.
Maintenant,
les trois principales qualités.
La première,
c’est la pertinence du propos.
90 % du temps,
l’élève est DANS le sujet,
et il persuade vraiment le lecteur que c’est
le cas
en répétant systématiquement
les termes clés du sujet :
« préférer »,
« toujours »,
et bien sûr,
il répète à l’excès « vérité ».
Retenez cette « technique »,
parce qu’elle est vraiment efficace :
un peu comme quand on écrit un article
pour arriver en première page de Google,
il faut répéter les termes clés pour persuader
le correcteur
de la pertinence du propos.
Deuxième principale qualité :
l’efficacité du style.
Oui,
ce n’est pas très élégant,
mais on comprend toujours
— et on comprend vite.
L’élève reprend systématiquement la même
triade
« Tout d’abord »,
« De plus »,
« Enfin » :
c’est monotone,
c’est mécanique,
mais ça ne risque pas de perdre le correcteur.
— il peut lire la copie facilement
et très rapidement,
le candidat lui facilite la tâche,
donc il le récompense !
Comme je le dis souvent,
la clarté du style est SURVALORISÉE en dissertation
:
si vous facilitez la tâche du correcteur,
même de manière grossière
(comme dans cette copie),
vous transformerez un 8 en 12 13,
un 12 en 15 16,
et un 15 16 en 18 19 20.
Enfin,
troisième qualité principale :
la qualité des références.
Elles sont toutes bonnes,
elles sont toutes pertinentes ;
certaines sont philosophiques,
d’autres littéraires.
Après,
il aurait pu mobiliser
quelques références originales
— surtout qu’il a cité beaucoup de références.
Là aussi,
il décroche la note maximale
alors que son travail n’est pas non plus
exceptionnel
sur le plan des références.
Alors maintenant,
quelle note mérite cette copie ?
Je viens de vous le dire,
un style efficace permet d’être surnoté.
En particulier,
un 16 peut se transformer
en un 19 20.
En l’occurrence,
je pense que la copie vaut moins que 16.
Comme elle présente de sérieux défauts,
et que le sujet était plutôt facile
— sur le thème de la vérité,
il était assez probable que les candidats
aient déjà traité un sujet similaire —
donc pour ces deux raisons,
les défauts
et la facilité du sujet,
moi je donnerais plutôt entre 13 et 15.
Comment expliquer que la copie
ait été surnotée à ce point ?
Je pense qu’il y a trois raisons principales.
La première,
c’est que le correcteur a dû la lire
très rapidement.
Mais bon,
les concours c’est comme ça
— c’est l’usine.
La deuxième raison,
c’est que l’élève facilite vraiment
le travail du correcteur
— donc il est récompensé,
c’est bien normal.
Enfin,
la troisième raison que je vois,
c’est que le paquet de copies
ne devait pas être terrible.
C’est sûr que si les dissertations corrigées
juste avant celle-ci
sont vraiment mauvaises,
eh bien par effet de contraste
celle-ci va paraître très bonne,
et le correcteur sera moins sensible aux défauts.
Bon après,
ce n’est pas scandaleux non plus.
Le candidat a eu un peu de chance,
mais c’est quand même un élève qui a
travaillé,
et qui maîtrise,
globalement,
l’exercice de la dissertation.
Alors,
qu’est-ce que vous devez retenir
de ce commentaire ?
Je pense qu’il y a trois leçons à tirer.
La première
— je viens de vous en parler,
mais je répète parce que c’est important
—
la première leçon à retenir,
c’est que vous devez faire le maximum
pour faciliter la tâche du correcteur.
C’est LUI qui tient votre sort entre ses
mains,
donc vous devez tout faire
pour vous le mettre dans la poche.
Ça passe par l’efficacité du style,
mais aussi par la propreté de la copie,
par la simplicité de la construction du propos,
et caetera.
La deuxième leçon,
c’est que le concours récompense les élèves
SCOLAIRES.
Il n’y a pas besoin d’être un génie
pour cartonner ;
il n’y a pas besoin de connaître tous les
plus grands auteurs,
ni de les avoir lus dans le texte ;
il n’y a pas besoin d’écrire comme Proust
;
il SUFFIT de maîtriser l’exercice,
et de faire ce qu’on attend de vous
— C’EST TOUT.
Avec cette copie,
le candidat n’a pris aucun risque :
il applique des techniques très simples,
il réutilise les mêmes formulations
— au point qu’on a l’impression
qu’il fait du copier-coller ;
il fait de mauvais choix,
commet des maladresses,
MAIS il fait ce qu’on attend de lui.
Je n’accepterais jamais de publier
une dissertation comme celle-ci
sur 1000 idées de culture générale,
mais pour une épreuve de concours,
ÇA SUFFIT.
Tiens :
pourquoi est-ce que je ne publierais jamais
une dissertation comme celle-ci ?
Parce que c’est
un MAUVAIS modèle.
Bien sûr,
le candidat a eu vingt sur vingt.
MAIS avec un certain correcteur,
dans un certain paquet de copies,
sur un certain sujet,
et caetera.
Ce que je veux dire,
c’est que la méthodologie de cet élève
n’est pas RÉPLICABLE.
Si vous dissertez comme lui,
vous n’aurez pas vingt sur vingt.
Et en réalité,
pas mal de copies très bien notées sont
de MAUVAIS modèles.
C’est ce que j’appelle
l’effet « retourné de Ronaldo ».
[EXTRAIT]
On est d’accord :
c’est un geste magnifique !
Mais est-ce que vous croyez que c’est
ce qu’on doit apprendre aux enfants
dans les écoles de foot ?!
Bien sûr que non,
parce que ça marche une fois sur cent !
Eh bien c’est pareil pour cette copie :
ne vous en inspirez pas,
parce que vous aurez vingt
une fois sur cent.
Si vous voulez apprendre une méthodologie
de la dissertation
qui marche à tous les coups,
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit par e-mail.
Le lien doit s’afficher maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
mais vous pouvez aussi le trouver dans la
description.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
et qu’elle vous sera utile.
Si vous avez des questions,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire.
Et puis souvenez-vous
que vous n’avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête
pour réussir une dissertation.